hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's now in this video I will be
doing absolutely everything I can to get
every last secret in the game and I
don't know if I'll be able to get
everything but I know I can get this
secret ending that I know is out there
it can't just be left up to them
scooping out my innards baby stepping
her way into my skin and then walking
out of this facility as a weird Robo
meat so the first step is the cupcake
game because I looked at my footage when
I was editing the previous video and I
know there's a way to get by everything
there's a way to jump over cupcakes hit
the right people and then go back at a
cupcake hit the right people again and
then do a final loop through with the
last green cupcake to get absolutely
everybody I'm not gonna explain it in
full because right now I just need to
get to it
but the next thing you'll see is be
actually in the cupcake game because I
just have to die over and over and over
again and I'm not gonna start the game
over just yet I may start the game over
to try to find other secrets but for
right now I'm just gonna try to die
again and again and again until I get
the cupcake game and then I'm pretty
sure if I get it once I've thought in my
head to how to do this right and I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to do it right
but I'm gonna do it the best I can and
you'll see not too many failures we're
gonna do this great job okay so the
strategy is you get these kids here you
do that what you need to do there
[ __ ] okay now this is where things
get a little tricky because what I have
to do here I have to left which means
that I need to leap over this one to
this platform here go over here and get
this kid if I'm not mistaken this is
right okay boink boink okay and there we
go okay so what I need to do is I need
to oh I don't know if I can make that
okay so [ __ ] okay so
Oh oh yes you can
okay this is a tricky bit oh no no no no
I went to quit now
oh [ __ ] yes okay okay don't mess this up
oh please yes okay all right
don't mess it up don't mess up oh don't
mess it up oh don't mess it up keep my
finger off the trigger - I don't waste
any goddamn copper cakes mmm
freaky freaky freaky freaky freaky prick
- dick ba ba ba ba ba Bam Bam okay just
like that just like that okay we got
plenty of time and there's really
nothing - I just got to remember that
one jump that's all kinds of funky if I
remember the funky jump which is not
here ah okay so BAM all right and this
one's the funky jump so I got a jump
here yes yes yes yes yes yeah yes I
scream whoa what do i what do i do again
what it did I do that right oh no did I
do it right Oh No lesbos go back to the
beginning oh come on
okay so I got all the kids so then I get
this
and then instead of going over there I'm
gonna go all the way back I've got I
think I've got plenty of time the music
change so there's got to be something
going on over here something different
something has to have changed right
right question mark good thing I jumped
over that other one because I would have
died if not but there's got to be
something back at the beginning and I
have no I'm gonna run at I'm gonna
retire it's gonna be down to the wire
way down to the wire oh boy cool boy
running out of time hangout time come on
come on come on I don't know what else
there could be it's gotta be something
it's gotta be something who else
o3 come on - come on oh no oh [ __ ]
well what do you do
was I not fast enough I was about as
fast as you could go oh did I do it I
don't know yes that's good yeah oh god I
think I did it
what did I do did I get anything
yeah okay look it's a two star it's a
two star no that's a forester it's a two
star - for victory however the [ __ ] that
understand lit my god you guys don't
know how long that took like holy [ __ ]
that was forever and ever and ever and
ever and ever that was like that was two
hours and 45 minutes that I was trying
that it was so annoying because it was
just like getting to the point where I
could make another attempt it only took
me like like like six or seven tries to
actually get it done but getting to that
point was obscenely difficult but I did
I did it now I gotta try to laughs going
to there to goddamn room that I hope
you'll hurt me oh man if this doesn't
work then I have no idea what to do
holidays I don't want to go through the
whole game again after that so now I
just need to send baby on her way and
then gun it for the private room because
I imagine it's like Mario shut up it's
like Mario and you need two stars to get
through the two star door that's how it
works right rapidly I'm gonna dick for
the private room access great yeah oh it
seems that you have accidentally
wandered into a restricted area of the
sensitive nature of the materials that
you may be exposed to here you will not
be allowed to leave until the cleanup
crew arrives at 6 a.m. so hang tight
rest assured that you will be promptly
rescued fired then sent home yeah not
for being an employee oh my gosh
experience has not been as regrettable
hours oh my god it's actually five noisy
Fridays holy [ __ ] yeah oh my god this is
probably gonna be obscenely difficult I
have no idea where anything is
what oh god is baby on the way
babies on the way oh [ __ ] this is five
nights at baby's cuz you're ugly and I
hate you
does this poster go Boop is golden
Freddy go Boop is this go booth dooby
dooby doo no no okay that doesn't work
apparently okay
holy [ __ ] I had no idea that this is
gonna all that's how good ah [ __ ] yeah
not at all nor did old oh [ __ ] dude okay
my god okay well [ __ ] I thought he was
gonna be gone he was actually get even
closer than before
oh geez oh geez
ah I don't understand why you're such a
douche because apparently you definitely
is douche can you please go away from
that goddamn door oh [ __ ]
where's he ah no the answer is I don't
Oh God Oh coming down the same Avenue
again huh well I can beat you at that
game this is no way I'm gonna lose to
you I mean there's every way that I'm
gonna use the Blues to you because I
don't know about my power consumption no
you didn't kiss
Weidman okay there's something to that
keypad okay
it's a certain code okay so good who's
that hi so we can do so you can leave
not we won nine and there's a code here
I'm oh jeez I'm trying to figure out and
survive at the same time and it's not
gonna work out too well
Fuji's Oh lay crap okay it's one nine
oh it's 1987 No is there more god damn
it oh [ __ ] I thought that was gonna be
it
oh jeez okay it's not there it's in 1984
No
I'm not gonna make it hi you get really
skedaddle II at 4 a.m.
ha don't you do I have to walk all the
way back there probably oh [ __ ]
Tori maintenance P well [ __ ]
alrighty then I see how this is ok this
time I'm gonna be a lot better about
those from Scranton about those uh you
know power it seems that you have
accidentally wandered into a restrict
how do to the situation of the materials
that you may be exposed to here that's
that's the house from five nights at
Freddy's 4 and the code was 1983 which
ties back to that because that was the
era that that occurred that was the bite
of 83 not the bite of 87 okay I don't
hear any movement I gotta conserve my
energy right now cuz I don't want to
play through the skin
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] that oh [ __ ] that I had
that
oh [ __ ] you I don't need this goddamn
game
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh boy [ __ ] man ho
that's so finely tuned
that's absurdly tuned Oh God not this
again god dammit oh [ __ ] dammit dammit
dammit god it's really close I have no
idea how close I am all I know is that
I'm really [ __ ] close damn it's so
close it's so fine tune it's so fine
tuned it's so fine tuned I got to do the
stopwatch thing cuz I just need to know
like what I'm doing man it's so fine
tuned I was very close like obscenely
close that time seven minutes in 30
seconds right there okay so this is me
talking to you from the future or the
past or whatever you want to call it I
was concentrating so much here that it
wasn't obvious what I was doing to you
guys the main factor in this moment of
the game is listening to auditory cues
there's noises that signify he's changed
locations in the three locations one
being Center right and left if he makes
a noise in that department that doesn't
mean that he's at the door it just means
that he's moved over to that area it's
only if he makes a second noise in that
area that I then shift my attention over
to say the right side right here and it
may not seem like I'm seeing
but when I flip up the screen I'm
actually gathering data you know I know
he's there or I know he got closer I can
see that it comes from my you know hours
and hours of practice of doing five
nights at freddys 2020 modes over the
years you know I'm very good at flipping
the screen up and just grabbing what
little detail I need to spare his little
battery as possible and then using
majority the auditory cues to know when
and where what to do things so if I know
that he's moved to one area I also know
that he can come back but I know there's
no danger unless he makes two noises in
the same field now this isn't always the
case because he does sometimes move
silently but that's very rare
that's what flipping the screen is
useful for so you know exactly when to
do something but here I've managed to do
it so I'll leave it up to me take it
away me in the past present or whatever
[Music]
oh got light at it whoa oh man oh I get
my last bowl of popcorn savage Maruyama
sway in the wind so also dual essence
way between star-crossed lovers you
burned down my house you call that a
house it was like a morgue in there
I may be undead but you're heartless you
need to see your son the baby isn't mine
he ate the cat sounds like something he
got from your side of the family well
how's this I'm keeping the diamond ring
the joke's on you I found it in a kid's
meal you bought a kid's meal Oh Clara as
the hair on the back of a cat stands up
straight so also does the love between
Vlad and Clara
stand up against all obstacles but what
about the baby
yeah what about the back child support
stay tuned next season hollows answers
and more oh I got my exotic butters
yes and I've buttered my popcorn from
all around the world oh the sweet taste
of victim it huh holy [ __ ] yes I did it
yeah I don't know how baby or whatever
then that was followed me home but holy
[ __ ] okay so in summary I was purple guy
I'm pretty sure that's how that went
because if mr. Afton is purple guy which
is established in the books and that is
his daughter that would explain why this
guy kept coming back especially after he
got kidnapped and that also explains why
he didn't die when he was manipulating
all the animatronics because you know
any untrained bum buh wouldn't know what
the [ __ ] to do but he does he knew
exactly what buttons to press
and it's obviously cannon that he didn't
die I don't know how that thing got all
the way out into my house how did it
drag its way over there I mean okay I
guess but wow it seemed damaged too so
what happened to it
that's the blue ending it was the red
ending and now this is the blue ending
well I did it place the crown upon my
head ow and then call me the gang of
five nice yeah oh my god show me my
three stars baby okay god damn it wasn't
like the the problem is it wasn't that
hard I mean again like the mini-game it
took me what six seven maybe ten tries
like I'm not exactly sure how many it
took but it wasn't a lot compared to me
doing twenty twenty twenty modes when I
do literally hundreds of attempts so
it's not that bad and I'm not flying
that one just took careful listening and
understanding what the listening meant
so this one was called a nerd like
innards his name is entered a nerd kinda
name is and nerd yeah whatever okay
Andrew did you
I'm gonna call you bum buh I'm gonna
call you dumb bum buh your bum buh and
I'll call you bum buh til the end of
your days bum buh so I don't think
there's anything new exotic butters
exotic butters exotic exotic butters how
long until someone makes a remix of
exotic butters exotic butters exotic
butters okay but I don't think there's
anything other than that I have my three
stars we just an might as well be
thorough yep okay and that is it so that
is all for five nights at Freddy's
sister location - the possibilities of
some more Easter eggs but those are
going to be almost impossible to find
but I bet people are gonna pour through
the game files and locate them sooner or
not or later but I like this I love this
game I want to recap and say that this
is probably one of my favorite five
nights at Freddy's games besides the
first the first will always hold a
special place in my heart
this one is this really cool because of
what it offered what it felt like to
play it now I do have some very
legitimate criticisms about it but as
far as like the secret ending with that
other room that was just annoying like
it was just annoying to have to go back
through that stuff and waste like three
minutes just to get back and make
another attempt that was annoying other
than that though I loved it atmosphere
was great voice acting was great the
semi free roaming of it obviously
limited by the engine that it was made
in was still really good I liked that he
gave a new dimension to the game the
mobility of it the fact that you're
going somewhere the fact that you're
traversing an actual area instead of
just watching it from the cameras and
yet at the same time it had that element
of watching and observing as well and it
had the last game at the end there that
literally was throwback to five nights
at freddys and a good version of it I
mean only a one version of it but is
still pretty good it combined the
listening of five minutes at Freddy's 4
with the other mechanics of everything
up other than we've ever done so all in
all I'd say this is probably this yeah I
don't know five nights at Freddy's 2 is
still really good so I'd say this is
probably the third best five nights at
Freddy's so far so it goes number one
number two and then this one so that's
my ranking anyway but either way thank
you all so much for watching thank you
for encouraging me as I go along in this
that took roughly like four or five
hours not nearly as bad as number one or
number two
but definitely took longer to get to the
very third star ending of the rest of it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
Oh
you